bienvenidos a la presentación de
momentos y solo por si lo llegas a notar
en este vídeo en realidad ya hemos
cubierto el tema de momentos quizás no
lo reconocí sé por qué lo cubrimos en el
tema de ventaja mecánica y de torca pero
lo que creo es que en estos temas
sobre complique lo que lo que tiene que
ver con momentos y quizás no cubrí
suficientes ejercicios clásicos que uno
ve justo en las clases de física
especialmente si no usan cálculo y todas
estas herramientas matemáticas más
complicadas ok entonces esencialmente
que es el el momento el momento y en
realidad estamos refiriéndonos al
momento dinámico que éste es el momento
dinámico y este momento dinámico como
habíamos dicho ya lo habíamos cubierto
en el tema de ventaja mecánica
de ventaja mecánica y en el tema de
torca
por acá muy bien y esencialmente el
momento es lo mismo que la torta ok el
momento dinámico este es momento
dinámico ahora qué es lo que estamos
diciendo con con todo esto de momentos y
thor casi demás si no has visto los
vídeos de torca sería muy buena una
buena recomendación que lo que los
checas en estos momentos también el de
ventaja mecánica pero sólo para recordar
imagina que tienes como una especie de
sube y baja es digamos
no sé un plano qué es eso
tiene soporte digamos en un único punto
digamos no sé éste pues digamos en este
triangulito ok y nosotros aplicamos una
fuerza digamos que de este lado estamos
aplicando una fuerza digamos esta fuerza
f 1 en una distancia digamos
vamos a llamarle a esta distancia de
donde aplicamos la fuerza a dónde está
el el eje digamos de rotación o dónde
está el el pivote vamos a llamarle a
esta distancia de 1 muy bien a esto de
aquí se le conoce como el brazo de
momento
un brazo de momento o que quizás sería
más correcto decir el brazo de palanca
en este caso si estamos hablando de una
máquina simple verdad el detalle del
momento y de la torca es que cuando uno
aplica esta fuerza para definir la torca
uno está pensando que esta fuerza es
perpendicular al brazo de palanca muy
bien entonces como calculamos la torca o
que ahora es lo mismo que de momento
simplemente como fuerza que es esta
fuerza perpendicular al brazo por la
distancia al al al eje de rotación o al
pivote o al cual fulcro muy bien
entonces este momento o esta fuerza
provocan una rotación verdad de hecho si
estamos aplicando la fuerza en ese
sentido pues esta rotación se digamos
ocurre en la misma dirección que llevan
las manecillas del reloj ahora bien para
para qué nos sirve todo esto imaginemos
que tenemos esta fuerza y por otro lado
queremos aplicar una fuerza f 2 digamos
no sé a lo mejor es más grande
efe 2 en una distancia a lo mejor un
poco más chica digamos que ahora que
esta distancia es de 2 muy bien si
estamos suponiendo que después de
aplicar estas dos fuerzas en estos
distintos puntos no hay una rotación de
esta palanca entonces lo que nos dice la
ley de los momentos es lo siguiente que
la fuerza 1 la fuerza 1 x de 1 que
esencialmente es la torca del lado
izquierdo es decir la torca
correspondiente a él la rotación en la
dirección de las manecillas del reloj
debe ser igual al momento efe 2 x de 2
que provoca una rotación y en este caso
sería en dirección contraria a las
manecillas del reloj
y como lo vimos en el vídeo de torca lo
que podemos hacer es por ejemplo este
lado izquierdo restarlo o pasarlo del
otro lado restando y que es lo que nos
queda nos queda efe 2
efe 2 x de 2 esime menos - f1 por de 1
debe ser igual a 0 y así es como lo
utilizamos en el vídeo de torca verdad
porque habíamos acordado que cuando se
produce un movimiento en esta dirección
es decir contraria a las manecillas del
reloj se tiene una bueno lo definimos
como positivo y cuando es era en la
dirección contraria lo definimos como
negativo verdad entonces eso es
justamente lo que tenemos en esta
expresión y ahora lo que quiero hacer es
que podamos realizar a lo mejor unos
ejemplos un poco más digamos concretos
con con numeritos y todo para que quede
mucho más claro
ok entonces vamos a trabajar en ello
para quitar esto digamos nuevamente que
tenemos nuestra palanca
que nuestro sube y baja y tenemos un
punto en donde estamos sosteniéndolo
aunque hay digamos aquí está el punto
vamos a suponer por ejemplo que de este
lado tenemos una una masa un bloque
quizás
no sé
un bloque que a lo mejor tiene una masa
de 5 kilogramos muy bien entonces si
suponemos que la aceleración debida a la
gravedad es de 10
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado que
digo esto por supuesto no es verdad la
aceleración es 9.8 aproximadamente
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado pero
bueno para hacer las cuentas más fáciles
dejémoslo de esta forma y entonces cuál
es la fuerza que ejerce este este este
bloque o este cuerpo la fuerza que
ejerce es masa por aceleración verdad
por las leyes de newton entonces a
partir de aquí esto ejerce una fuerza o
un peso de 50 newtons verdad fuerza es
masa por aceleración ahora vamos a
suponer además que estamos ubicados
justo a 10 metros de nuestro pivote muy
bien estamos a 10 metros de nuestro
pívot ahora vamos a poner del lado
derecho una masa más grande
digamos este desde 10 kilogramos y
queremos saber a qué distancia tenemos
que ponerla para que esta palanca o este
sube y baja se encuentra en equilibrio
es decir no no provoca ninguna rotación
entonces nosotros sabemos que otra vez
este ejerce una fuerza o un peso de 100
newtons verdad porque ahora es masa que
es 10 por aceleración que son 10 esto
ejerce un peso de 100 newtons la
pregunta es cuál debe ser esta distancia
esta distancia de aquí para que tengamos
que esta barra se encuentre en
equilibrio entonces lo único que tenemos
que hacer es utilizar la ley de los
momentos verdad y simplemente tenemos
que calcular la torca del lado izquierdo
que es la que es actor acá produce una
rotación en dirección contraria a las
manecillas del reloj mientras que la
torca del lado derecho produce una
rotación en la dirección
en la dirección justo de las manecillas
del reloj o verdad
justamente entonces estos dos tienen que
igualarse así que vamos a tener del lado
izquierdo que la torca se calcula como 5
newtons por 10 metros y esto debe ser
igual a la fuerza que son 100 newtons
por la distancia por la distancia muy
bien y ahora lo único que tenemos que
hacer es despejar la distancia del lado
izquierdo que es lo que tenemos 50
newtons por 10 metros estos son 500
newtons por metro y del lado derecho
tendremos simplemente 100 newtons por la
la distancia que no conocemos así que si
dividimos entre 100 newtons vamos a
tener lo siguiente que la distancia la
distancia es de 500 entre 100 son 5
metros y esta es nuestra distancia la
cual tiene que estar nuestro bloque de
y esto por supuesto confirma como que no
estoy de intuitiva que teníamos quizás
de niños cuando íbamos al parque verdad
y simplemente si a lo mejor teníamos una
no sé había un niño que tenía una mayor
masa que nosotros quizás porque nosotros
estábamos muy muy flacos cuando éramos
niños a lo mejor en ese entonces lo que
podíamos ver es que siempre que un niño
más grande estaba del otro lado del sube
y baja nosotros nos quedamos arriba
verdad y eso era por efecto de ésta de
la ventaja mecánica que se produce al
estar en el sube y baja verdad ahora
bien si ese niño a lo mejor estuviera
más alejado en sobre sobre el el sube y
baja entonces a lo mejor
no más bien si ese niño más grande
estuviera más cerca del pivote entonces
a lo mejor si podríamos mantenernos en
equilibrio así que vamos a hacer otro
problema un poco más complicado ok vamos
a hacer un problema un poco más
complicado vamos a bajar esto muy bien
vamos a tener nuevamente nuestro sube y
baja nuestra palanca
muy bien y digamos otra vez que está
apoyado en un punto en un pivote muy
bien ahora vamos a tener varias fuerzas
digamos que aquí está lo que vamos a
poner aquí el cero y que a una distancia
de ocho a la izquierda es decir en menos
ocho sobre este eje vamos a aplicar una
fuerza que va que provoca una rotación
en dirección de las manecillas del reloj
de 10 minutos no se puede pensar que
alguien está tratando de levantarlo a
esta distancia vamos a pensar que ahora
quien menos 6 en menos 6 hay algo que
produce una fuerza hacia abajo
digamos este de 5 newtons no sé estoy
inventando números espero que no no haya
ningún problema con este ejercicio
aunque entonces aplica una fuerza de 5
newtons a una distancia 6 por la
izquierda de nuestro pivote y que eso
genera una rotación en dirección
contraria a las manecillas del reloj y
digamos que también tenemos otra fuerza
digamos a quién
no sé en -2 que va hacia arriba y esta
fuerza es de 10 donde vamos a ponerlo
todavía más raro de 50 newtons ok esto
es del lado izquierdo y voy a poner con
morado todo lo que provoque una rotación
en dirección de las manecillas del reloj
y en verde voy a dejar las que van en
dirección contraria a las manecillas del
reloj muy bien ahora digamos que acá del
lado derecho
va a haber una fuerza hacia arriba una
fuerza hacia arriba de 6 newtons y lo
pongo de verde porque esto va a provocar
justo una rotación en dirección
contraria a las manecillas del reloj y
digamos que esta fuerza está localizada
a tres unidades de donde se encuentra el
pivote ahora vamos a aplicar una fuerza
de este lado a una distancia 10
no sabemos hacia dónde va hacia arriba o
hacia abajo
digamos vamos a suponer ahorita que va
hacia arriba ok una fuerza f tenemos que
calcular cuál es la fuerza necesaria que
hay que aplicar a una distancia 10 para
que esta palanca se encuentre en
equilibrio y vamos a suponer por ahorita
que va hacia arriba es decir que se
produce una rotación en dirección
contraria a las manecillas del reloj
porque si llegara a salir negativa
entonces significa que no va hacia
arriba sino que va hacia abajo ok
entonces hay que calcular esta fuerza y
otra vez tenemos que utilizar todo lo
que hemos visto sobre torque y momentos
para ver cuáles es y lo que tenemos que
utilizar es lo que vamos a tener que que
emplear es el hecho de que el momento
dinámico de digamos que produce una
rotación en una dirección debe ser igual
al momento dinámico que produce una
rotación en la dirección contraria
así que fijémonos primeros en la torca
producida por estos vectores morados
entonces para el primero recordemos que
es fuerza x
distancia y la distancia aquí aunque
tiene menos 8 en realidad es 8 verdad
tenemos 10 por 8 aquí es pero no te
confunde al menos el menos simplemente
está diciendo hacia qué lado estamos
moviéndonos a partir del pulcro del
pivote ok y este si le sumamos el otro
la otra torca digamos 50 por 2 verdad
que es fuerza por distancia esto es lo
que tenemos como torque que produce una
rotación en dirección de las manecillas
del reloj y esto ya vimos que debe ser
igual a la torca en la dirección
contraria es decir 5 por 6 más
la fuerza que es seis por tres más
la fuerza por 10 verdad está blanca muy
bien así que vamos a vamos a tratar de
calcular estos 10 por 8 son 80 2 por 50
son 100 esto debe ser igual a 5 por 6
que son 30 más 3 por 6 que son 18 más 10
veces esta fuerza muy bien entonces aquí
me faltó poner 80
unos 880
verdad así que tenemos 80 más 100 estos
son 180 debe ser igual a 30 más 18 que
son 48 más 10 veces nuestra fuerza y
entonces aquí no sé por qué no puse
estos son 180 muy bien son 100 más 80
son 180 ahora sí a 180 le restamos 48
que es lo que nos queda son 132 verdad
son 132 es igual a 10 veces la fuerza y
eso quiere decir que nuestra fuerza es
132 entre 10 que son 13.2 newtons muy
bien así que esta es la fuerza que
necesitamos emplear para poder mantener
esta palanca o este sube y baja en
equilibrio y en efecto estaba bien
nuestra intuición verdad si iba hacia
arriba hacia arriba esta fuerza entonces
para este tipo de ejercicios sólo debes
tener en mente que la torca neta en una
directa que produce una rotación en una
dirección debe
ser igual a la torca neta que produce
rotación en la otra dirección nos vemos
en el próximo vídeo